We've been talking about labels and
their use in mandatory access control.
Now we're going to get
to a concrete model.
This is a model that deal
with confidentiality and
it was introduced earlier is
the Bell and La Padua model.
Project that developed this model was
funded by the Department of Defense,
so the kind of label we're going to
talk about are the type we've
been discussing, where you have
classification and clearance and
things like that.
Couple of things to keep in mind here is
that confidentiality is the issue here.
We're concerned about
the disclosure of information.
So more sensitive information we don't
want that to be disclosed to someone who
is not cleared at that level.
So that's going to be one.
And since we're talking with DoD
the other thing to keep in mind is
the labels what they're
going to look like.
As I said, the DoD means it's going
to assume that information or
data that's contained in files
is classified at levels like TS,
top secret, secret, and
classified and so on.
The second part of a label
is a compartment or
category that as we said before.
It depends, what is the document about.
So is it chemical or nuclear or
conventional or two kinds or
something like that.
And the rule for read says user with
label L1, top secret user, for example.
Who's working on, let's say,
nuclear and conventional.
So that would be this
user's compartments.
So user with label L1 can read document
with label L2 only when L1 dominates L2.
So this domination that we defined
before when the label of the subject or
the user dominates the label of the
document, then they're able to read it.
This is called the read-down rule.
You can read documents that
are classified at your or
a level that's below yours.
Or further down from your level.
So that's the read-down rule.
It's also called the simple
security property.
So how about writes?
Because you both need,
you need to address both read and write.
So user with label L1 can
write document with level
L2 when L1 is dominated by L2.
This is saying the user has to
be at a level that is lower than
the level at which
the document is classified.
Which means if the user is secret,
he can write a top-secret document,
he cannot write
an unclassified document.
This is the write-up rule.
So you can read down, but
you have to write-up, and
it's called the star property.
So let's just see what's the sort
of rationale for writing up.
Remember, our focus is
on confidentiality or
disclosure of information.
This model says more sensitive
information cannot flow.
Well, the information flow
control requirement that we had.
So more sensitive information
should not flow to users
who are not cleared at that level.
It's basically focusing on disclosure.
It doesn't say anything about
who can write information.
That's sort of an integrity question and
we have to revisit that perhaps.
But if I can write at my level or
at a higher level.
If I could write at the lower level,
then what could go wrong?
Well, I may have in my possession some
information that is more sensitive.
If I write it into a document that's
at the lower level, then someone who's
cleared at the lower level can in
the future come and read that document.
Which means we would have
information flow from a more
sensitive level to a level and to a user
who should not have access to that.
So, you can't allow write downs.
You can question why would
an unclassified user have information
that is top secret?
But if they did write a top secret
document, a top secret user would read
it, as information flow from
unclassified to top secret.
But that doesn't,
while with the confidentiality
requirement that we have.
So think about, a request comes.
User has the users label.
The target is a document that the user
wants to access, had its own label.
We can do this comparison
if the read request is,
user is making a read request.
Then the user label better
dominates the documents label,
to satisfy the simple security
property of the read-down rule.